hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast investigating the role of
micro RNAs and pancreatic cancer
progression presented by Sylvia
Ottaviani research associate Imperial
College London I'm Alexis Clouse of
leopards and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is brought to you by labyrinth
and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information on our
sponsor please visit thermo Fisher comm
now let's get started before you begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button well
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentations please click on the
support tab found at the top-right of
the presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the answer a
question box located on the far left ear
screen this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
I'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr. Sylvia Ottaviani Sylvia is an expert
in non-coding rnas biology and cancer
she is currently a postdoctoral
researcher at Imperial College London
looking at the role of non-coding RNAs
in cancers mainly pancreatic and breast
cancers Sylvia's research has been
predominantly focused on micro RNAs
however more recently she expanded her
work on long non-coding RNAs - Sylvia
has recently published her main
postdoctoral project in Nature
communications journal where she
investigated novel micro RNA is involved
in the tgf-beta response and pancreatic
cancer she is also co-author of several
publication on micro RNAs cancer and
she's author of two comprehensive
reviews on the role of non-coding RNAs
and health and disease for complete
biography on dr. Ottaviani please visit
the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr. su Vianney
you may now begin your presentation
hello everyone thank you for the
introduction and thank you everyone for
signing today so I am Sylvia Vianney
and a postdoc researcher studying the
role of non-coding RNAs in cancer in
particular pancreatic cancer so unveiled
at the division of cancer at Imperial
College London in the UK and I work in
the laboratory of dr. leandra Castellano
and professor just in stabbing today I'm
very excited to talk to you about how
our lab is studying the role of micro
names in pancreatic cancer and in
particular I will present the results of
my first postdoc project there has been
recently published in Nature
communications so let's get started so
pancreatic cancer is a lethal disease
with a 5-year survival rate of
approximately 6% it is currently the
fourth highest cause of cancer deaths
and it is predicted to be the second
leading cause of cancer deaths in the
next decade if outcomes are not improved
specifically ductal adenocarcinoma is by
far the most common malignancy of the
pancreas
it is indeed the focus of the majority
of the research in the field certainly
from our laboratory so sometimes that we
refer to this as P duck so the reasons
why a pancreatic cancer is associated
with very poor prognosis are primarily
the lack of early diagnosis and
ineffective treatment for advanced
tumors additionally pancreatic cancer is
characterized by remarkable resistance
to most conventional treatments so
tomotherapy and radiotherapy as well as
molecular target therapy therefore every
research effort to improve our
understanding of the molecular
mechanisms that drive this aggressive
disease is crucially important and will
allow development of more effective
treatment
so I'm sure you're all familiar with
Mike Rene's here I just would like to
highlight some important points
so Mike Rene's are small non-coding RNAs
that negatively regulate gene expression
through mRNA degradation or
translational inhibition this is just an
overview of the biogenesis pathway so
briefly Micra nails are transcribed as
primary micronized by RNA polymerase 2
the prime ike renee is then cleaved by
the micro processor which is a complex
including russia and DG cr8 this
cleavage produces the 6070 nucleotide
precursor microlight the Premack renee
is then exported to the cytoplasm by
exporting five and further process by
dicing one to produce the mature mike
Renee so one strand of the mature Mike
Renee is loaded into the RISC silencing
complex which directs the matron aid to
the target mRNA by sequence
complementarity and may be a gene
suppression as we said by either mRNA
degradation or translational repression
so microwaves are fine-tuned modulators
of gene expression and they regulate a
variety of biological processes so
perhaps it is not a surprise the fact
that this regulation of mic renee
expression is involved in cancer so
indeed mike Renee's can function as
tumor suppressor and oncogenes so here
on the left panel we can see a schematic
representation of the biogenesis of
micronet that we just discussed in
normal tissues so the overall result is
normal rates of cellular growth
proliferation differentiation and cell
death in a middle panel we have an
example of a reduction of the mic Renee
the functional tumor suppressor so that
leads to tumor formation so the
reduction of mic renee levels can occur
because of defects up at any stage of
micronesia
biogenesis and why we have this question
mark and ultimately lead to the
inappropriate expression of the micron a
target uncle protein so the overall
outcomes may be increased proliferation
and invasion and Genesis and reduce cell
death leading to tumor formation in the
last panel we have an example of
amplification or over expression of a
micronized that has an oncogenic role so
this would also result in tumor
formation in this case increased amounts
of the mic Rene would significantly
decrease the levels of the target tumor
suppressor gene and lead to cancer
progression so increased levels of
mature mic Rene might occur because of
amplification of the Micronesian or a
constitute constitutively active
promoter or increase efficiency mic Rene
biogenesis or indeed increased ability
of the mic Rene and those are all
indicated by these question marks what
about Mike Rene's in pancreatic cancer
obviously as in many other cancers many
Mike Rene's have been identified and
shown to have a role as oncogenes or a
tumor suppressor so this is a table of
selective mic Rene's identified there
might be clinical clinically relevant in
the management of pancreatic cancer so
as you can see Mike Rene's have been
identified acting as oncogenes in the
top part of this table or tumor
suppressor in the bottom part and they
are involved in many different
biological processes a one goes through
the list in details I would just mention
a couple for example a very well known
on camere in pancreatic cancer is near
21 over expression of mir-21
contributes to gemcitabine ECAM
resistance and honam's malignancy of
pancreatic cancer cells ms4 tumor
suppressor a very well known tumor
suppressor is the left 7 family of
Mike Rene's and seven was found down
regulated in a number of pancreatic
cancer cell line and it induces
reversion of EMP in gemcitabine
resistant cells so our laboratory is
interested in studying the role of
micronized in pancreatic cancer
tumorigenesis and progression here I'd
like to point out two important studies
that were published in the laboratory so
in the first study we performed a micro
expression profiling in pre malignant
pancreatic tumors compared to P Doug in
order to identify Mike Rene's
deregulated during Pedic development so
we found many Mike Rene that were down
regulated in P duck compared to low
malignant tumors and we showed an
amongst those micronized downregulated
min 16 mil hundred and twenty six and
seven D regulate known P duct oncogenes
so bcl-2 K rats in c RK the fourth down
regulation of mu 16 126 and led 7d
promotes Pedic transformation by post
transcriptional up regulation of crucial
Pedic oncogenes in the second study we
combine data from micro named mRNA
expression profiling in Pedic cell lines
and also interior samples from patients
to identify the micronized that
contribute most to tumorigenesis so we
identify three micronet mir-21 near 23a
and miR 27a that acted as a cooperative
repressors of a network of tumor
suppressor genes that included PPD cd4
ned Pharrell and dtg2
in addition we have shown that
inhibition of mutiny one mill 23a
and mill 27a had synergistic effect in
reducing proliferation of period cells
in culture and also tumor growth in mice
so moving on we decided to concentrate
on specific pathways that are relevant
in pancreatic cancer so this is an
overview of the aberrant signaling
pathways in pancreatic cancer it is
important to mention that the majority
of tumors around 90 95 percent of all
cases are driven by mutational hyper
activation of Kara's so this downstream
signaling is excessively activated we
decided to focus on the tgf-beta pathway
as tgf-beta as a vital role in Pedic and
at the time the words and a
comprehensive study of micronized
regulated by tgf-beta so briefly
tgf-beta binds to the type 2 TJ beta
receptor which activates the type 1
receptor and this leads to the
activation of my 2 & 3 transcription
factor and in the couple then with my 4
and they translocating to the nucleus to
regulate smart regulated genes so um so
tgf-beta signaling has a vital role in
pancreatic cancer as well as in other
cancers and it has a dual role so it
acts as a tumor suppressor in the pre
malignant stages of tumorigenesis and
then switches to an oncogene role at
later stages of the disease so the most
dominant functions of tumor suppressor
are growth inhibition and apoptosis and
the dominant functions as oncogenes are
EMT invasion and metastasis and feminist
so we decided to focus on the oncogene
functions of TJ theorem
so how does teachers be trying to use
EMT metastases and stamens in pancreatic
cancer and this is a very simplistic
representation of the molecular pathway
but I wanted to point out some of the
important factors so as we said before
tgf-beta activates mod 2 & 3 which in
turn form a complex with smog for to
simulate the expression of pro EMT genes
such as nail twist and that this lead to
a repression of epithelial genes such as
ECOD earring to activate the EMT program
and at the same time the MU 200 family
and is a very important family of
micronized and they've been shown to be
very highly expressed in epithelial
cells so they maintain the epithelial
phenotype and they do this by repressing
Zab 1 & 2 it has been also shown that a
new 200 family micronet is active
stemness inhibiting micronized because
they suppress your report and respect
transcription factors such as the a BMI
1 Sox 2 and klf4
so simply the aim of our study was to
identify the micronized regulated by
tgf-beta in pancreatic cancer that had
not been identified before so we wanted
to uncover whether micronized could add
an additional layer of regulation in the
complex signaling of tgf-beta responses
so to discover noble matron is
implicated impede our progression
through tgf-beta we created an in vitro
cell line model of EMT spectrum
specifically we use
exp c3 cells that are very epithelial
and then we use penguin cells that are
par superior impartment Thank You mo and
then we treated penguin cells with EJ
speed up for 72 hours and as you can see
from the picture at south 3d we tgf-beta
they abduct a more spindle shape and
mesenchymal like morphology and finally
we have food to double 7 cells that are
highly mesenchymal so here on the bottom
left you can see a Western blot for
appearing in these lines and as
expecting you can appreciate that the
expression of appearing are inversely
correlated with the mesenchymal status
of the cells so next we perform micron a
expression profiling using encounter
system and from nano strain and this is
a heat map that shows a selection of up
and down regulating micronized from the
analysis so we confirm that the mere 200
family members are done regulated in
Mazon chemo like cells compared to the
epithelial exp c3 cells and and
excitingly from the analysis we found
that only two micronized Mir 125 be
increased proportionately with the
mesenchymal status of the cell and so we
validated this result by qPCR so here we
can see the stepwise increase of the
level of both mere 100 and 125 B with
the mesenchymal status of the cell and
also we can see that these micro names
were significantly up regulated by
tgf-beta so an actually wanted to
investigate the mechanism of speedy
speed a regulation of these micro names
so firstly we looked at the genomic
location and found that near hundred and
near 125 be together with let-7 a came
from the same primary transcript the
long non-coding RNA me 108 G so mere
hundred h3 is a Tresa Stronach hot
stream for these micro names so our
first question was in is the teacher
speed a regulation of these micronized
transcriptional so in order to answer
this question we performed
RNA seek in penguin cells treated with
tgf-beta as expected tgf-beta
significantly up regulated pro EMT
factors and unregulated cell to cell
junction proteins like a keyring
interestingly and we mill hundred h3 was
amongst the rnas significantly up
regulated by tgf-beta this therefore
indicates that the induction of a 100
and 125 v by tgf-beta is indeed
transcriptional so the answer is yes so
next we wanted to investigate whether
this regulation was occurring through
smart 2 3 transcription factors we
therefore performed chip seek for smart
2 & 3 as you can see from these tracks
you can appreciate this math 2 & 3
interact with several regions of the
mere hundred Hz gene with strongest
binding around the transcription start
site however we later appreciated that
even in the absence of this main site
tgf-beta was still a
able to induce these micro names
suggesting that smart 2 & 3 may use
other sites more intensively to regulate
near 100 HD expression in the absence of
the main ones so even though the
regulation of this transcript was more
complicated that initially saw the
regulation indeed happen happens through
is my 2 & 3 transcription factors so the
answer of this question is the SS one so
to summarize we think the tgf-beta
activates mod 2 & 3
that in turn binds to mere hundred Hg
locals and induces other expression the
player the primary transcript is
elevated that eventually the mature
Micra nays are elevated this will make
sense except for one expects
you
so and I told you before that mere 180
is the Tresa Stronach ha streams for me
100 125 B but also let 7a and here's a
problem and we are saying that mere 100
and 125 B are oncogenic Mike Renee is
upregulated by teachers beta and let 7a
as discussed before is a very well known
tumor suppressor Mike Renee so any rise
of let's 7a levels following me Hondo GG
induction would serve to counteract this
effect so what is going on
we decided to look at the kinetics of
those three micronized upon tgf-beta
treatment as you can appreciate from
this figure while sneer hundred and a
mere 125 be increased throughout the
time course let seven a initially rise
and then goes back to the initial
untreated levels so indeed in our also
in our micron a profiling which 72-hour
to G beta treatment less than a was not
significantly up regulated so this data
suggested that let seven a is repressed
at the post transcriptional level by a
factor that is possibly regulated by
tgf-beta so a very well known inhibitor
of let seven processing is Lin twenty a
Lin 28 a them amb Lin 28 can he may be
let's amend through several mechanisms
it combine two prior let seven and he
may be the processing by the
microprocessor or a combine to pray let
seven and he may be the processing by
Dicer or it can induce degradation of
prelate seven by promoting a legal you
read elation by the tooth enzymes so we
looked at our RNA seek data and found
that Lin 28 B was indeed significantly
up regulated by tgf-beta instead in 28 a
was was not expressed at all so and we
looked at the expression of Lin 28 be in
the same T G beta time course and found
that Linton a B starts accumulating a
six hours you have the RNA at the top in
the protein level at the bottom a six
hours when let-7 a level starts to go
down we also further validate is finding
by showing that in knockout South Faline
28 be tgf-beta was able to induce less
than a levels and validating our funding
so before going into details of how this
micronized effect AMT and feminist
phenotype I wanted to summarize here the
main method of manipulation of Mike
Rene's so there are a wide range of
methods that can be used to manipulate
micron a level and here at least is the
one that we use in the lab and in
particularly I've used with this project
so in terms of transient manipulation we
have usually perfected in transaction of
precursor micronized forever expression
and anti micronized for inhibition as
possible manipulation we used precursor
micron a expression linty vectors and
sold by system Biosciences and for
knockdown we've used the music anti
micronized special entity vector and
again from system Biosciences or we use
the CRISPR no couch of micronet local in
terms of the music technology and the
music plenty vectors expresses a short
hairpin RNA that after processing
preferentially produces an antisense
might Rene so this results in a stable
accumulation of anti micronized that
literally zip the mic Rene leading to
permanent mic Rene inhibition
to evaluate whether this micronized
regulate EMT we firstly looked at the
morphology upon transient over
expression using pre macro names so we
did this in three different cell lines
and you can appreciate that upon the
over expression the cells become more
spindle shaped characteristic of
mesenchymal cells we also employed
immunofluorescence staining to see
whether these micro names were acting by
reducing occur during levels as you can
see from the red staining ECOD earring
is still expressed
however we observed a mere 100 induced
disruption of akkad earring at the level
of cell to cell junction and near 125 be
promoted a complete de localization from
the junctions
and we next look at the opposite process
so Matt which is mesenchymal to
epithelial transition and in order to do
that we used a stable knockdown clones
using music technology and we've used
the cells that express these mirrors at
the highest level which are the suit to
double oh seven and so as you can
appreciate from the morphology here the
knockdown cells they acquire more
epithelial Sano type and also we have to
reuse these cells to assess motility and
we perform the wound healing scratch
assay and you can see that in the note
down south for mere 100 and 125 be the
motility is indeed impaired and next we
wanted to investigate the role of these
micro nails in cancer stem cell
formation and so this is because the
activation of EMT programs has been
associated with the acquisition of stem
cell trades but normal and your plastic
cells so and the gold standard technique
to look at cancer stem cells in vitro is
the sphere formation assay so it
consists of feeding cells in low
attachment conditions without serum at a
very low density in these conditions all
in cancer stem cells survive and they
will start dividing forming spheres so
the number of spheres is a proxy for
stemness so it top left we have
increased number of spheres upon trends
in over expression of the meal and in
the left bottom panel we have reduced
number of spheres upon transition
inhibition of Micra names and here on
the right again we have reduced number
of spheres in the stable note down
clones
what about invivo so to assess whether
me one hundred and hundred twenty-five
be regulate your initiation capacity of
pancreatic cancer we performed a serial
dilution assay in nude mice using the
suit to double seven stable not down
clones so you can appreciate that the
knockdown showed a strong reduction of
tumorigenesis and and here using the
highest dilution we have formation of
tumors in all conditions however the
knockdown cells are for much smaller
tumors next we looked at metastases so
this is a schematic of the method that
we employed and the firstly we generated
luciferase stably expressing cells so
that we could image the cells in vivo
and we then injected the cells into the
spleen of nude mice and cells through
the portal vein we reach the liver which
is the main is a static site for
pancreatic cancer and after one week we
remove the spleen to avoid growth of a
primary tumor there and we track the
cells by imaging using the ID system we
then sacrifice the mice and perform some
experimenting and this is the bottom are
our results and so knocked down for me
125 B was very effective in reducing
liver metastasis and for me 100 we
noticed a trend but it was not
significant and this mirrors the effect
that we had in our in vitro assays where
it seems that the effect of me 125 B is
always more significant than mere 100
right then the obvious final question
was how important are those micronized
in the context of tgf-beta response
meaning if we inhibit the function of
this mic renée's and we treat cells with
aegis beta are the teachers be the
responses impaired the answer is yes so
here on the left and you can see a
reduction of sphere formation in a couch
mic Renee clones treated with tgf-beta
compared to wild-type cells treated with
ajust beta and here on the right you can
see the tgf-beta the tgpd induce
motility is impaired in knockout cells
so in this experiment we use the CRISPR
technology to knock out the micronized
and briefly this was our strategy so in
both cases we use pair of sgrna to
disrupt the micron a locus
so these deletions made impossible for
the lockers to be transcribed and
therefore we had no production of mature
micronized just very quickly I will
touch on the clinical relevance of these
micronized so here we perform in situ
hybridization from mid 100 and 125 be in
a collection of 100 Pedic samples and
quantify the micron expression intensity
so we found that high near hundred and
near 125 bit levels were associated with
both reduce overall survival and reduce
disease-free survival
but so far we have shown that these two
tgf-beta regulated micronized are
involved in several and overlapping
phenotypes that could be explained by
the regulation of multiple targets so
we've developed a novel approach for
target discovery that we called reviews
so RNA in you know precipitation
followed by ambient sequence enrichment
analysis so this method is developed in
several steps firstly we overexpress the
mic Rene of interest in cell lines in
our case we overexpress me 100 and under
25 be in Punk one cell then we perform
in parallel I go to rip seek to reveal
transcripts that were significantly
enriched in a go to and RNA seek of
total RNA to reveal transcripts that are
functionally repressed by the mic Rene
able to target interaction this is
followed by unbiased even Richmond
analysis using Salama
as is shown here or Seward's algorithms
to identify the motifs or micron a
target interaction finally to test
whether the motives identified also
inhibit the expression of those genes we
perform cumulative cumulative
distribution analysis using RNA seek
data and I won't show the results but
basically in our case for me 100 and 125
be the three prime UTR of transcripts
that were loading onto able to upon over
expression of the smears were also
strongly enriched with their seed
motives as expected transcript
containing the canonical seed was
significantly downregulated compared to
transcripts lacking these motives so the
great advantage of reviews is that we
can identify direct targets that come
from the overlap of able to read seek
data in the downregulated genes from the
RNA seek data so considering this over
up we perform pathway analysis using the
IPA software and as a result of these
analysis we notice that these micro
names were regulating common pathways
including p53 signaling apoptosis and
the role of check proteins in cell cycle
checkpoint control and this is just a
summary of the micronet argot
interaction based on repute and also
they're grouped in the most significant
pathways so as you can see micronized
this Micra name is regulate many targets
and are involved in many different
pathways so finally this is a schematic
representation of our proposed model so
TG Spira
by as much as three induces
transcription of mere hundred h3 which
drives up regulation of mere 100 100 125
B we have shown that tgf-beta induces
all Selene 28b to keep 7a levels and
change these micro names regulates many
common pathways to induce EMT and
feminists and the 4p duck progression so
to conclude I would like to thank
firstly my University Imperial College
London that allow me to share my
research with you to diet of course my
mentor dr. leandra Castellano was a
great supervisor and a brilliant
scientist and taught me all I know about
non-coding RNAs in cancer I'd like to
thank also Michael supervisor professor
Justin sebong and all the lab members
those are just the ones that were
directly involved in my work and helped
me greatly with this publication I'd
like to thank the collaborators that
were directly involved in my work so dr.
Luka mignon II and prof. long Yahoo from
Imperial College London and Professor
Christopher adhesion from bars Cancer
Institute in London and dr. Elissa
jovanotti from the Cancer Centre in
Amsterdam and of course I like to thank
the funding bodies for this study
we're mainly pancreatic cancer UK and
action against cancer and if you want to
know more about this word this is the
article describing my project and was
published in Nature communications last
May and also obviously I'd like to thank
everyone for signing in today and listen
to this presentation I'm happy to take
any questions or comments you may have
also I welcome you to connect with me on
Twitter or LinkedIn if you like and
learn about the research in our
laboratory at Imperial College thank you
very much
you
you
thank you dr. Shivani for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the far left to your screen well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
question is you've showed the
correlation of these two micro rna's
with overall survival and disease-free
survival in patients are high levels of
these micro RNAs also correlated with
great or differentiation of the primary
tumor and yeah this is such a great
question and yes we have performed these
analyses and so we've done the
correlation between a 100 and mere 125 B
we grade of differentiation in the
hundred patients samples so we actually
discovered that only high mere 125 B and
not high mere 100 was significantly
associated with higher tumor
differentiation grade
thanks for the question of course dr.
tehrani
what is the next stage for these
microRNAs yeah this is a knob vyas
question I guess we are very excited
about this work so with this work we
found that those two micronized could be
important target for therapy so now we
are really working to try to bring those
targets closer to the clinic so we are
setting up a model of nanoparticle
deliveries in order to deliver those
anti micronized and we are setting up 3d
model cultures as well so we can test
this a nanoparticle on on 3d model and
eventually we're going to move a to in
vivo studies
and our next question is can you expand
a bit more on the transcriptional
regulation of mere 100 h d by s mad 2 2
& 3 yes
so yeah apology I went a little bit
quick on that slide but so we've
basically realized that mahadji has a
quite complex regulation so from the
result of the initial much of a chip
seek and we thought it was quite clear
there's my 2 3 were strongly binding at
the transcription start site and in fact
I can just bring the slides back so you
can follow me a little bit better so
that's slide 14 and then here we go
so we should see the chip seek track now
and so and so yeah so we've seen this
very strong binding the transcription
start site so to ultimately prove that
these by disease were the most important
region we deleted this region with
crisper and thinking that if we don't
have this locus then obviously when we
treat this as we teach of beta we won't
have the induction of the micronized
anymore however when we did this
experiment after deleting part of the
table the promoter we did see low levels
of mere hundred Hg and also low level of
micronized but teacher Spira was still
able to induce near 100 and 100 a
hundred thirty five B so then we looked
actually in details and we found that
actually mere hundred h3 as multiple
transcription start site according to
we've looked at h3k27 acetylation and
markers and also we can see other
mattress rebinding throughout the
transcript here you can see in replicate
to
you can see some other bonding not so
much in replicate one but we've checked
some cheap seek data from other
laboratories for example from Pedic
cells isolated from mice and we see
clearly multiple binding throughout the
mere 180 gene so therefore we are Aperta
sized that actually is not 2 & 3 may use
other size more intensively to regulate
980 expression in the absence of the
main ones however we're pretty sure the
regulation of this transcript is
occurring so this mod into 2 & 3
in fact we show that if we knock down as
my twins 3 bias RNAs we completely
abolish the TG speed and use regulation
of a mere 100 125 B levels and and also
we showed that the the mere mere hundred
and mere hundred 25 B level they start
increasing very early after TG better
treatment and indicating that this is a
very direct mechanism from teacher
speeder through as much 2 & 3
transcription factors I hope you thought
earlier now o you we're getting some
very very interesting questions right
here so here's maybe our next one how
far away are you from conducting
clinical trials and patients with this
exciting potential therapy yeah this is
some this is very good question so we
are really working really hard now to
try and as I said at the beginning to
try to use these targets eventually in
in a clinical setting but I think that
realistically we're talking about around
10 years time I would say because we
need to set up all the delivery system
and we need to test it in vitro in vivo
and then ultimately we can start testing
inhuman so in clinical trials thank you
and I look and it looks like our next
question is going to be why did you
inject the cells interest into the
spleen for pancreatic metastatic assay
could you explain this model over
orthotopic injection of cells in the
pancreas yes absolutely this is this is
a very good question so and we've we've
decided to do the spleen injection and
because it's a very accepted
experimental model to generate liver
metastases of course you can inject
cells also topically in the pancreas and
spontaneously they and they will form
you wait and then we for metastases
however this is this is a quite long
process so the beauty of the splenic
injection is that is a very quick assay
so after injection in the spleen the
cells reach the liver
within minutes so I suppose the
limitation of this method is that with
the splenic implantation of cells and
you we can measure the ability of the
cells to grow in the liver but we're not
able to look at the detachment of cells
from the primary pancreatic tumor
followed by invasion and astronomer so
it is it is a good method but it really
looks at is really looking on at the
experimental model of liver metastasis
yes
s mad for is frequently mutated in
pancreatic tumors perhaps one could
hypothesize that the downstream
mediators of tgf-beta might differ
between s mad for wild-type in a mutant
can you tell us the estimate for status
of the cell once you have used in the
study yeah this is that is a great
question and it's absolutely right so as
mud for mutation occurs very frequently
and we think around 31 percent of cases
so in our study
did you feed a mediating induction of
this mic Renee seems to occur only in
punk one and also call us three five
seven cells and also in them we have
some kpc derived cells so cells deriving
from pancreatic pancreatic mouse model
and so all of those cells are well type
for smartphone and so we think and also
when we checked the we check the
regulation in BX PCC and suit to double
oh seven cells and there is no
regulation by tgf-beta in those cells do
not express mud for and we've shown this
experimentally as well but yeah this is
a very good question
and it looks like we are going to have
time for one more question I'm a bit
unclear on why Ricky's would offer a
significant advantage over more
conventional methods for example over
just combining RNA sequencing Scylla
more and targets current predictions
yeah this is a this is a good question
so basically we reap use so we are
talking about combining a go-to vape
with Salama or C words and RNA sick
after expression of the microneedle
interest we can obtain accurate
identification of direct targets and
important information also about the
type of regulation
so in particular I a go to rip ego to
rip experimental identify the
transcripts that are directly bound to
the micronet interest and this can
happen through canonical or non
canonical and see the interaction if you
were to use only RNA seek let's say
combined with salami on target scan you
could be direct target that act through
non canonical see binding because target
son would only look at canonical seeds
so in addition we found that if we use
salami in rip seek data is it gives a
very very good results and it is much
superior a detection of micron
interacting side compared to RNA sick so
in fact when we try to use salami after
in RNA seek we didn't see any clear
significant signal for canonical micro
no interaction side so you cannot in the
identify neither canonical or non
canonical sides and and finally I'd say
that reviews is you allow to establish
whether the identified motive there are
canonical and non-canonical are actually
capable to down-regulate the transcripts
and for example alternative method like
lip and clash experiments have indeed
demonstrated that some micronized
interact with transcripts through
seedless regions but because these
methods are not combined with RNA sick
they cannot indicate whether these
non-canonical interactions are
functional for target regression so yeah
thank you again dr. Viviani
do you have any final comments for our
audience now I'd like to thank everyone
and I hope and this presentation was
useful for for you and please get in
touch if you have further questions or
comments and yeah at any point oh you'll
want to know a bit more of what we do in
the lab thank you before we go I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
that you provided at the time of the
registration we would like to think we'd
like to thank dr. ativy ani for her time
today and for her important research we
would also like to thank leverage and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through January of 2019 laboratory via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye